the Joe Rogan experience long story but
like after my debut I'll go back to this
but like pretty much the the Bronson
fight before it was when I realized how
you eat affects how you think and how
you feel your mental health
no sure cuz beforehand before the fight
before us I couldn't wait I was eating
like [ __ ] like literally just cuz you
know I cut away easy so I'm eating
everything whatnot and then throughout
that camp I was getting like I hurt
myself as well remember I mentioned I
had to post fight press conference and
then I had to take a whole week of
training this is like five weeks out and
I had to make the call like [ __ ] we're
gonna pull from this fight so we don't
leave it too late so they can find a
replacement or take a whole week off
come back Monday and then see how we
feel and then doing that I ain't write a
proper you know I was a little bit like
the president [ __ ] like that cuz it was
even already but that week transitioned
everything just cuz the way I was eating
and the way I looked after my body and
then when I got back to camp
boom and I realized through that camp
and also reading Charlemagne's book as
well the shook ones oh yeah it kind of
helped me I listened to it yeah I
listened to it too
so yeah yeah well that's a good one to
listen to - because it's read by him
yeah he's such a sunny interesting Orion
and the way reads that because I listen
to brilliant it's as well yeah he's on I
mean like for a guy like him to talk
about being [ __ ] up with anxieties
like people like what you talks about
crazy [ __ ] nah people don't understand
man like even my boy chance he's with me
right now you know like for me I like to
cuz I'm on this journey now I like to
take those that came up with me I bring
them on this journey like I went to
Dubai I brought my brother with me so I
can inspire him I went to Nigeria I
brought a B with me you know cuz he's a
Nigerian I told him after this trip like
be careful cuz you're gonna you know
holiday blues you know like when you
come back from a holiday you feel like
oh and everyone all these Instagram
hosts post take me back you know
with the bikini shots and whatnot that's
all in my wing get back home you're
gonna feel it and I know because I've
experienced it as well after my UFC
debut
I literally my half the party was three
hours of just hi nice to meet you honey
now what I literally went to go hide
somewhere and some guy found me he's
like bro you all right what are you
doing I'm like I'm good I'm just chillin
just taking five minutes alone oh yeah
now you understand a and just sat next
to me I'm just like
alone means you ya here [ __ ] and
then after I go home
like you know go to bonus got a nice
check from the UFC and then got
depressed down the cycle the feeling
yeah like I'm home alone with my own
thoughts noise like what the [ __ ] I
didn't get that do you understand this
well even just cuz of everything else
happening I started seeing a therapist
straight away just because I felt like
no one teaches you how to be famous
there's no [ __ ] book about and I've
seen a lot of people at athletes movies
singers rappers and rise and fall and
I'm not gonna be one of those people you
watch house but then I went to a
therapist from October from February to
October just kind of like learn some
tools to help me with this and then so
after my first fight that happened my
second fighter half of my third fight
Brad Tavares fight main event [ __ ]
all the stimulus it's like coffee you
drink coffee and then you get all the
stimulus you're hyped and he come off it
and crashed yeah I quit I quit it's the
same thing and then those tools that I
got from my therapist really helped me
just kind of like navigate back so New
York was the first fight I got back to
my house and I was i right boom I know
how to attack this I know what's gonna
happen and I was anticipating
because beforehand I didn't anticipate
the hype that was gonna happen the wave
after the fight like after this fight I
already know what's happened like I knew
was gonna be like more than everything
I've done in the UFC already so I braced
for it and I'm prepared myself and I had
the right people and the right tools to
help me ease back into my regular
routine so I went back home and was just
easy what was the feeling of depression
because obviously you had this
spectacular result you won yeah and then
but what what was it what was the
feeling like what was bothering you
if I think about in my debut when I got
back home sit down um it was just like I
don't know and that's no I hate trust me
I love [ __ ] the perks [ __ ] Fame I
don't like me a famous but I love the
perks a lot of perks but like when you
get back home and I'm with that's why I
like hanging out my dogs on my cat cuz
they don't say anything I can just be I
can just exist with them I don't have to
entertain them I don't have to talk
right contrary to popular belief I'm
more always extroverted I'm a Coast baby
I'm a crab lion
cancer leo
I can go you know both ways you know
God's alright job but you know but like
yes I can when I'm home by myself
I'm just very reserved I like to be my
own thoughts I like to be in my own
space you know like well Jorge had to do
in Panama or wherever he works yeah and
the feeling was just not it's almost
I've heard of impostor syndrome
mmm-hmm I I'm not sure if I'm saying it
if I'm using her right but I don't know
I want I don't want to say that's what I
had but like you almost feel like you
don't you don't belong yeah like I don't
belong I don't deserve this everybody
everybody has yeah so what so I had to
go through that for my first flight my
second fire my third fight and like I
said it wasn't until the Bronson fire I
just decided to [ __ ] own it
because in New York there's this clip on
YouTube of this guy he's walking around
Times Square normal just chillin nor
pays attention to him and then he goes
to he goes comes back at nighttime and
then he's hired like security camera
crew he dresses the part and he's
walking around trying square he's just a
regular do like a YouTube content
creator and then everyone's done - like
who's this guy oh can I take a photo
yeah cool take a photo yeah cool and
then like the camera guy goes up to
random people and goes like so how do
you know his name's Brian how do you
know Brian how do you in there like ah I
saw him in spider-man you know yeah I
think is pretty good you know and then
let the guy go to another guy you know
so what do you think about his last
album but I uh I mean I didn't hear the
whole thing about her to single on the
radio and people just lying through
their teeth lying through their teeth
about what the [ __ ] this guy is when
they don't even know he was I
experienced that at DejaVu [ __ ] crazy
in Times Square in New York Madison
Square Garden I experienced that in Time
Square like literally shooting for my
brand engaged shooting some shots for
them so is a better crew around me my
crew around me and I'm not even trying
and at one point I kind of just cuz I
I'm always noticing everything around me
and I see people like some people
recognize where I was and then I saw
people like I can hear them like who is
he and the same person will come amen
big fan you'll Can I grab a pic I'm just
like all right take a pic and the next
person like aints and hi can I get a
picture
and just take a picture and they don't
know who the [ __ ] are they somebody
likes you exactly there's ah he's famous
and they just want to get that shine so
[ __ ] like that kind of humbles you and
lets you know you can get caught up and
all that [ __ ] man
talk about hype a lot and I'm like [ __ ]
it just own it New York was when I
decided like I'm not gonna feel like I
don't belong just own it this is my life
now well I think what you're doing is
you're taking the mentality of a high
level striker and you're applying it to
Fame because you don't wanna get caught
in traps you don't see all the pitfalls
like if your your chins up
you drop your hand if you you have a
tendency that someone can exploit you
got to go home make sure I mix this up
make it show them different moves you
you you don't want to get caught in
traps yeah I don't want to get caught
never yeah that's but that is also what
happens with Fame if you get caught in
your own traps you set your own traps
yeah I know I make my own mistakes I
won't crash into a pregnant lady Bobbitt
my own mistakes sorry I'm taking all the
shots
come get it whoa
[Applause]